i'm really glad to see that more and
more
uh fox news hosts are being confronted
with the hypocrisy of their going
completely crazy about the vaccine
mandates that are being put in place by
various companies while not mentioning
that fox news itself actually has a
stricter mandate than that which most
companies have and that which was
proposed by joe biden for companies of
100 or more employees so yesterday we
had this clip from fox and friends where
they completely unbelievably said we
don't have a mandate we have a protocol
we looked at the definition of the word
mandate we looked at the definition of
the word protocol and we determined uh
they have both it's it's the same thing
it's a distinction without a difference
it's a difference without a distinction
whatever word or phrase you want to
apply to it uh it was bs and it was not
believable
today we're going to go and look at
another one of these confrontations and
this one is with tucker carlson
now this one's really interesting
because tucker carlson has been one of
the most
sort of prominent
purveyors
of the attacks on vaccine requirements
even saying the vaccines don't even
really seem to work and the vaccines
might have killed thousands of people
and all these different things media
matters has a great article on this fox
personalities trying to distance
themselves from fox's vaccine mandate
even though fox news's requirements for
unvaccinated workers are stricter than
those recommended by the biden
administration network hosts continue to
attack vaccination policies and
compliance protocols fox personalities
and guests have insisted the mandates
and testing requirements are akin to jim
crow laws
apartheid
eugenics
forced sterilization
and discrimination against those
affected by hiv aids
the biden administration policies fox
has spent months demonizing
require companies with a hundred or more
employees to ensure that staff is
vaccinated or test weekly
fox corporation's policy is get
vaccinated or test daily
and enter your status into an online
portal more than 90 of fox employees
report being vaccinated okay so now
um
[Music]
this is great this is a clip from save
the nation vince and jason
and they bring this to tucker carlson on
october 13th he does this maniacal laugh
take a look at this okay so i i have a
question here about fox news um yeah
you said fox news has no vaccine mandate
but according to newsweek the company
requires unvaccinated employees to
submit to daily covid testing which is
stricter than biden's mandate which
calls for weekly testing right
businesses that employ more than 100
people is fox news denying the civil
liberties uh of its employees by being
stricter than president biden fair i
don't know i mean you should probably
ask newsweek it sounds like they got a
pretty precise handle on what's
happening
right so that's not a serious answer all
right but let's continue hey
if it's wrong let me know if i'm wrong
no
yeah
it's it's
it's completely wrong as i noted the
other night
um i'm not
you know so what is the policy
for the company
um on this but as an employee so that's
that's just that's just you know bs
as an employee he could speak to his
understanding of the policy he's
subjected to i mean he's subjected to
the policy so you don't have to speak
for the company because i don't run the
company and i'm not
you know i'm just an employee of the
company um
my personal press tell us as an employee
the policy you've been subjected to and
that you've agreed to reference is that
fox news
would you know make a statement about
what its policies are but i think like a
lot of companies
um you know they're hesitant to do that
because like why would you even want to
get involved in that conversation here's
the bottom line
you know there are a lot of infectious
diseases out there a lot and
a lot with much higher mortality rates
than covid19 true and you know there's
hiv of course there's tuberculosis of
course there are a bunch of different
varieties for hepatitis which have
killed
many hundreds of thousands of americans
over the years etc etc etc etc
and employers are not empowered in fact
they're not allowed to ask employees
what their status is are you hiv
positive really can you be test should
we test people so notice that this is
this is now
a gish gallop
okay
there's no vaccine for hiv
first and foremost okay
secondly we're talking about asking
employees vaccination status not disease
status
number three
hiv is far less contagious than covet
it's a sexually transmitted disease it's
i hope people understand the way in
which this is a verbal ink plot there's
no real substantive answer here based on
their sexual but hiv isn't a
communicable disease in the same way
like
you can't
you can't sneeze on somebody and give
them hiv right because he has killed has
killed
tens of millions oh yeah
now that's a different now now notice
how the goal posts are different
the death toll of hiv over
40 years now is different than how
contagious it is
it also i mean
you can't just walk by someone and they
sneeze and you have hiv
um this is really i don't think tucker
is this stupid so i think this is just
bad faith
i don't doubt that but you can't it's
not a communicable disease in the same
way you have to have sex or share blood
correct
well sure
at which point you
transmit it so it is by definition
communicable yeah and he said it's not
communicable in the same way and he's
right now and it's communicable in the
same way
that's my point just to be clear
i am
totally opposed to asking anybody his
hiv status
so now
look at what he's doing
this is a it's really a clinic in
disinformation now tucker is saying he's
against the thing he mentioned
which is not even analogous to covet
vaccination status he now says
covet he so he's he said covet
vaccination status is analogous to
asking hiv status and he's against he's
not saying ask people hiv step we're not
even talking about the same thing
anymore the first question was
doesn't your company have a stricter
policy than the one biden suggests which
tucker got out of by saying
listen i don't i don't speak for fox
news
i'm totally opposed to asking his
prostate cancer status
or what
prostate cancer now now we're in now
we're in lulu you know looney land
uh when we now with pr
prostate cancer hiv is communicable
through flu
through sexual contact sexual fluids
blood
now with prostate cancer what are we
even talking about this has nothing to
do with medical privacy his you know
latest blood sugar levels are i mean we
have hipaa laws for a reason so i'm
hired to do a job
and now now raising hipaa hipaa has
absolutely
nothing to do with this whatsoever so
look at the way in which tucker is
unable to give any serious answer
fox's policy is stricter than the one
biden proposes tucker first says i don't
speak for fox news no but you're an
employee you could tell us what they
told you you could tell us what decision
you made about going with it in order to
continue working there that's number one
he doesn't answer
then he goes into
hiv
then he goes into hiv status versus
vaccination status
then prostate cancer
then hipaa this is not about hipaa hipaa
has to do with the transmission of
medical records and privacy by medical
providers we're off the deep end folks
so
look at how quickly he fell apart under
just basic questioning
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
it is the hottest part of the year right
now if you're a guy who wears
traditional underwear
you know about the sticking and the
rubbing and the chafing not something
you have to worry about with sheath
underwear which is designed with
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front
which prevent skin on skin contact
keeping everything separate dry cool and
comfortable
sheath actually just re-released two
limited edition styles the flower of
life
featuring a stylish enamoring flower
pattern and bold geometric waistband
the other limited edition style is the
mesh airflow specially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability sheath underwear was
designed by an iraq war veteran who was
looking for a way to keep himself dry
and comfortable in the hot desert and
the underwear he developed ended up
being perfect for just about any context
in everyday use sheath underwear is
giving my viewers 20 off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman